the big question for today is whether
conservative mps feel that this is now
the time for the prime minister to go
that this is so damaging that he should
not lead the party into the next
election and while the received wisdom
has been that we've now heard a lot of
this that the prime minister is probably
safe for now i think it's important to
remember that there are a lot of
conservative mps there are 360 odd
conservative mps who we don't hear from
who have been saying that they are
reserving judgment until they see the
full extent of this what happened and
what were the leadership and judgment
failures that sue grey talked about in
her interim report and how much the
prime minister was personally
responsible and you you do hear that
from conservative mps and alastair
campbell articulated a bit of that this
morning this is what he told us
have these people got any self-respect
whatsoever do they not go home to wives
and husbands and kids who say to them
i'm sorry you cannot defend the
indefensible any longer so it was wait
for the police it turned out he broke
the law then it was wait for sue grey
and they say well whatever sue grey says
as you just said we know the story
anyway the metropolitan police have got
a lot of questions to answer about the
extent to which they investigated this
properly and also okay the one fine is
enough to sink this guy
because he insisted quotes there were no
parties
we know he was at them
look the trickiest bit of this k is to
explain why the prime minister stood
there in parliament and said there were
no parties and all the guidance was
followed when even if he was only found
have broken the law once that clearly
wasn't the case in a lot of these
gatherings which he appears to have
witnessed that's going to be tricky i
expect he'll also talk about some of the
changes he's already made to personnel
and the structure of number 10. but i
think the big question today undoubtedly
it's going to be tough undoubtedly it's
going to be damaging is this one tough
day or is there a longer hangover from
this or whether the prime minister can
with the help perhaps of a cost of
living package we expect later in this
week later this week recover some of his
lost authority